Clowns are the creepiest children's entertainers
on Earth, so naturally, they've been used
to terrify and delight grown-up film fans
for decades.
From homicidal aliens to juggalo cowboys,
here are our picks for the four best - and
four worst - clown movies of all time.
If you haven't seen Terrifier, congratulations
on your ability to sleep a full eight hours
without waking up in a cold sweat.
An indie film that sat on the shelf for a
few years before being released, Terrifier
is one of those rare horror movies that doesn't
seem to feel the need to over-explain its
villain.
The audience knows that he's a clown, and
he's probably demonic.
But that's about it.
He's silent, grinning, and more than delighted
to go on a trip to Slaughtertown any time
he can.
Terrifier is a low-budget horror movie spinning
off of an even lower-budget short film, and
it's got "love letter to the good old days
of horror" dripping off of it like viscera
off a clown monster's chainsaw.
It has gory practical effects.
It has party girls getting mutilated.
And if you're down with slasher throwback
sickness, it's 100% worth looking up.
Yes, 1990's TV version of It is charming in
it own way.
It's a slice of horror filmmaking from a simpler
time.
But it's just a bit agonizing to watch without
the rose-colored glasses of nostalgia.
Don't get us wrong: Tim Curry's performance
as Pennywise is fantastic - it's the movie
around him, hampered by a made-for-TV budget
and content restrictions, that hasn't aged
well.
There's the barely-animated giant spider at
the conclusion.
There's the rough acting and the dramatic
screaming about Pennywise being too mean.
There's the filmmakers' steadfast faith in
the usually outstanding Harry Anderson's comedic
stylings being able to carry the day, only
to watch him uncharacteristically drop the
ball.
"Come on, Tozier, get a grip."
Just shy of three decades later, It holds
a place in pop culture history as quite possibly
being the reason that every other millennial
seems to be afraid of clowns.
Watched with fresh eyes, though?
Not very scary at all.
The words "so bad it's good" have been thrown
around so much that they've pretty much lost
all meaning at this point.
Cultural interpretations of what's camp and
what's just vanilla-flavored lameness ebb
and flow over time.
Somewhere, floating atop the tides of our
willingness to accept silliness, there is
the unsinkable ship that is Killer Klowns
from Outer Space.
Killer Klowns is a tough movie to sell on
paper.
No two ways about it, it's the story of a
species of alien invaders who look, act, and
accessorize like clowns.
Their ships look like a circus tent and they
kill with an array of weapons, including pies.
If that sounds like a good time to you, you're
in luck: There are rumblings of an upcoming
sequel from the original creators.
John Wayne Gacy's list of real-life atrocities
is so long that we'll likely never know the
exact number of deaths for which he was responsible.
When the details of Gacy's crimes are laid
out, most people are inclined to instinctively
recoil in horror and disgust - but a small
sliver of the world's population veers left
and says, "Now that's a picture!"
"I'm a very important man."
Released in 2003 under the names Gacy and
The Crawl Space, this true-crime depiction
of the life of John Wayne Gacy juxtaposes
his sadism against his gigs working as a clown
for local events.
Exploitative, sensationalist, and featuring
Adam Baldwin from Firefly, it also stars the
guy who played Pee-Wee's bully in Pee-Wee's
Big Adventure in the title role, so it just
might ruin your childhood.
When it was first announced that Stephen King's
It was being re-adapted for the big screen,
fans of the 1990 TV movie might have been
skeptical - but that lasted exactly as long
as it took for them to see Bill Skarsgård
in character.
Yikes.
Look: The new It movies aren't perfect.
The CGI can be less than impressive, and there
are unsatisfying moments.
But as adaptations of million-page books about
trans-dimensional ageless horrors go, they're
a hoot.
They manage to pull believable performances
out of the child stars, which is sort of the
filmmaking equivalent of landing on Mars.
And Bill Hader is a revelation, which came
as no surprise to fans of his masterful work
on HBO's Barry.
"Maybe this is all I'm good at.
I don't know."
1989's Clownhouse is a slasher in the same
vein as every other low-budget entry in the
genre from that era.
It follows the story of three brothers being
stalked by a trio of escaped mental patients
dressed as clowns and lusting for blood.
There are misunderstandings and mixups, as
tends to happen in these situations.
At one point, a young Sam Rockwell - in his
film debut - gets stabbed into unconsciousness.
The movie ends with a title card reading,
quote, "No man can hide from his fears; as
they are a part of him, they will always know
where he is hiding."
And you know what?
That would've been an okay ending to an unremarkable
and largely dull movie if it wasn't for the
real-world horror happening behind the scenes
on the set of the film.
Director Victor Salva abused one of Clownhouse's
child stars, and was convicted and sentenced
to three years in prison - ultimately serving
less than half of his sentence before popping
back onto the scene to direct Powder in 1995.
His career has continued with movies like
the Jeepers Creepers franchise, and a constant
low-grade public curiosity as to how this
guy still has a career.
Cult filmmaker Bobcat Goldthwait is a national
treasure.
Once a comedian known for his aggressively
annoying persona, he's become a director whose
movies tend to be tragic, complicated, peculiar,
excessive, and agonizing.
Before World's Greatest Dad and God Bless
America, he wrote and directed a movie called
Shakes the Clown, and it's been dividing critics
and audiences ever since.
The elevator pitch version is that it's the
story of an alcoholic birthday clown who's
framed for murder and has to outfox the borderline
Mad Max-level gangs of performers who rule
the entertainment circuit.
The more complicated version is that it's
Goldthwait's representation of the comedy
cliques that exist at every open mic community
in America.
Some critics called it amazing.
Some called it terrible.
Perhaps the highest praise came, believe it
or not, from Martin Scorsese, who called it
"the Citizen Kane of alcoholic clown movies."
"Okay.
Salud!"
Over the years, it has become almost a rite
of passage for a successful band to dip their
toes into the world of Hollywood.
The Beatles had classics like Help! and Yellow
Submarine.
The Spice Girls irrevocably changed the geography
and political structure of the Earth when
they terraformed the planet into a newer,
better Spice World.
And in 2010, a posse of chemically imbalanced
clowns proved once and for all that just because
you can't figure out magnets doesn't mean
you can't run a camera.
Big Money Rustlas is the long-awaited follow-up
to 2001's Big Money Hustlas, the first Insane
Clown Posse movie.
It's set in the wild American West of 1837,
for some reason.
Visually, it appears to have been shot on
a budget of whatever loose change was wedged
into the cushions of their Insane Clown couches.
The script seems to have been less "written"
and more "found somewhere."
Big Money Rustlas was pretty obviously a movie
made for the fans.
It's goofy and weird, but if you don't care
at all about ICP, the whole thing is just
borderline unwatchable.
"The name's Wolf.
Sugar Wolf.
As in AAAAAAAOOOOOOOWWWWWWWW!”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
cinematic clowns are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.